it is a pleasure and honor to have the
legend himself on the day that uh we all
refer to his uh austin 316 comment the
the man the legend himself toting his
broken scobier uh which is available
today on steve austin day 316 stone cold
steve austin good to see you sir good to
see you again man how you been man it's
good to see you uh it's been a while uh
i'm living in nevada now i moved out of
here i still maintain a place here but
all things are going great and uh thanks
for shouting out the beer i'm real proud
of this beer we got it right there
austin 3 16 day you know a quick quick
bit of history please i did invent
austin 3 16 day the fans did when i cut
the promo at king of the ring in 1996
you know i referenced austin 316 says i
just whipped your ass
you know over the course of time you
know just because march 16th is 3 16 on
a number date they said you know they
kind of
unofficially officially made it my day
yes so thank you very much where's the
camera thank you very much to the wwe
universe who have made this actually a
national thing so what better day to
release a brand new beer yeah exactly
and so again the origin of
stone cold steve austin oh you just did
you just crack it open just cracked it
open it's go time steve all right you
want to go ahead and let's go give it a
whirl right there there you go there's
brockman
what do you got what do you got it's
fantastic i'm not gonna pour it all down
my shirt like steve used to but
no that's proper response i mean if
you're a beer lover like like the ipa
we're still really pushing the ipa and
that's a great beer i really kind of
gravitated towards you know the hops
but you know the the people you know the
people that don't really drink ipa says
man please make a lager please make a
lager we listened so we made a damn good
one and it's is it brewed right around
the corner from here el segundo brewing
company myself and the owner rob crocks
all hit it off a long time ago like two
peas in a pod you know i don't really
speak technical beer language but i can
tell you what i like yeah he knows what
i like and we put this beer together and
we just love it it's a partnership made
in heaven i love it that's the best now
is it that's is it stone cold over there
it's been cold it's been sitting on the
desk all day but it's still very cold
and it's very delicious well with all
due respect to aikman's beer you can
remove his canned food
not here right now
very good me and trump follow each other
i'll take the challenge with troy any
day of the week yeah yeah yeah big fan
troy wears troy uh uh congrats on your
beer as well that's right
here in the super bowl and he left us
some so brockman's got that in front of
empty cans all over fantastic
fantastic and again uh you can get that
uh beer where where what on your website
or something like that yeah go to broken
spirit go to brokenskullbeard.com for
availability near you because we ramp up
distribution but we're trying to make it
all across america right now as we speak
okay i got steve austin right here on
the rich eisen show on nbc sports on
peacock sirius xm and our terrestrial
radio audience is now back here uh on uh
steve austin day the man himself the
legend with his broken skull beer steve
austin here on the program and you just
mentioned moments ago the origin story
of steve austin day like you didn't say
anything to just try and create one it
just got created based on what you said
back in the day what's the
give me the back story on on you saying
austin 360. well what happened was you
know we were it was it was a
tournament-style pay-per-view call king
of the ring whoever wins king of the
rings he's going to get a little bit of
a push sure so you know they decided you
know i was going to be the guy that's
going to get that push in the first
match of that night i was wrestling mark
marrow he did this kind of fancy move
and he ended up kicking me in my mouth
and putting my top lip wide open well
that'd take me to the hospital to get
stitched up so while i'm gone getting
about 14 16 stitches in my upper lip
yeah
jake roberts was you know he's going to
be my next opponent and he had kind of
mentioned uh you know that he needed god
to help him through this it's kind of
religious based promo it's where he was
you know at that stage in his life as
soon as i stepped out of the ambulance
coming back i just had a pair of shorts
on i had my gear on and everything and
michael hayes comes up to me and he goes
hey i just want to let you know when you
were gone jay cut a release a promo on
you i said well what'd he say and he
kind of told me words to the effect of
what he said
and i said oh as soon as he said that
austin 3 16 popped into my mind because
back in the day in the old football days
they always had to john 3 16. posters
behind the you know the point after or
the field goal attempt right yeah and i
said oh man i got one for his ass
and so i just spun that thing together
and we went out we went out there you
know i wrestled uh jake was a short
match because you know
his ribs had been injured and we don't
want to injure my lip anymore
short match go over there do the promo
with the guy that told me about the you
know promo michael hayes and i just let
it loose pretty much an ad-lib one of
the things when you're on the fly and
just gold starts happening right
and i said austin 3 16 says you i just
whipped your ass and then as i kept on
vince was doing the announce and i knew
i needed a button on the end of that
promo and that something i just pulled
out of thin air i'll say that yeah just
pulled out of thin air and that's the
bottom line because stone cold said so
so i got two trademarks at uh oh i hit
two grand slams at two at bass at an
event i was never supposed to win
so you know it was just something i
capitalized on the timing was right i
was right and i was ready so magic
happened that night and so then it just
organically as we say right yes just
gained steam where fans started making
t-shirts or w did the did the wrestling
federation make the t-shirts up well
that was that was a funny thing when i
had come in you know mark henry uh mick
foley vader so many guys were starting
their debut about the time i came in
well i was coming in from you know a
torn tricep wcw a little bit of a stay
in ecw
and i didn't have a really good look i
didn't have this complete package that i
had you know now or today back then yeah
today
they didn't see no money uh in me and
one of the guys that ran a merchandise
jimmy miranda sweetheart of a guy
and i'd always you know be sitting in
the bleachers waiting on the show to
start and i'd see jimmy talking to
everybody about the shirts and i said
jimmy i said the office has ever got any
t-shirt ideas for me
nope not yet stephen
well hell after that austin 3 16
promo i was sitting there in the stands
one day and he goes
jimmy came up came up to me to go
stephen the office finally has a t-shirt
they wanted to do a t-shirt for you got
any ideas i i use correct languages i
said you god dang right i do
i said put a shirt put in austin 316 on
the front put a skull in the back and
carve in stone cold i said there's your
shirt so they produced a shirt and there
was a number one selling shirt in the
history of the business
i imagine so the ragamuffin was
marketable
[Laughter]
stone cold the best shirt of all time
the best shirt ever and like wore that
shirt to it disintegrated i still have
my original shirt that i bought in
pittsburgh's civic arena in 1997 i still
have that shirt at home i mean it's it's
iconic and rich what steve said about
his two promos that's like scoring five
touchdowns in the game and throwing
seven touchdowns in the game in the same
game like
what he did yeah in that one promo it's
a
do you think it changed wrestling steve
to be honest because that kind of
ushered in the attitude era
well i don't know maybe the attitude
there was kind of artist
i've always considered you know people
in that business to have attitudes
anyway but i guess it defined an era and
then it became that but you know going
back to those shirts
uh my niece is going to law school in
new york she just took the bar
and then my uh daughter here in l.a was
shopping at these thrift shops is the
thing to do right and they find these
vintage shirts and they're priced at
like 265 dollars and like you know back
in the day those shirts are 25 shirts
and you know
that's like bill murray was saying
stripes chicks in new york paying top
dollar for this stuff
[Applause]
i guess what's old is new again right
yes
sorry that's okay don't worry about it
it happens but it's it's amazing it's
amazing how how things uh and now
you're going to go to dallas for
wrestlemania 38 home of the dallas
cowboys man
uh on april 2nd and 3rd that'll be seen
right here on peacock i mean amazing
what if i told you back today you're
going to be wrestling wrestlemania 38.
i told you it's full of something i bet
right yeah but you know what this
opportunity comes up kevin owens starts
running me down and gets my attention
and you know what it was a thing where i
kind of
said you know i'm never going to get in
the ring again and in this business they
always say hey never say never
and but i said i would never get in but
you know prompted by the right person at
the right time hell i actually wish you
to piss me off a little sooner than it
did to give me a little bit more time to
prep because once you go into that ring
man that's just like stepping on a
football field or you know into a
baseball diamond or onto a hockey rink
that's where business happens and so we
don't know what's going to escalate to
but you know really been working on my
on my conditioning
and you know had it been anywhere else
other than you know
jerry's place yeah down there i saw
george strait on the cowboy rides away
tour sold out 103 thousand and it was
amazing so it's a two-night event you
know wwe is the biggest show of the year
i mean wrestlemania is the biggest show
of the year so to be a part of that is
really special to me and it get it you
know
i'm doing this for me i'm gonna go out
there and i'm gonna have a damn blast
i'm gonna have fun and i'm i'm gonna
wear i'm gonna wear these two fists out
on kevin owens and i'm sure he's gonna
get some too because he's had an amazing
career and i'm glad
that he pissed me off when he did
yeah why can i well can i give you a
story yeah long time ago when i was
still active in the ring i was on the
road somewhere i think we're in canada i
was about to get on an airplane and this
kid comes up behind me it was kevin
owens helmet another guy he goes he's
stone cold he goes my name is kevin
owens you know i just want to know i'm
in the business a couple years can you
give me any advice
and he started telling me about all the
offensive moves that he was doing stuff
like that and i said kid i said you need
to stop doing all those crazy moves and
learn how to run your mouth
he go i said you need to learn how to
cut a promo
and
kevin owens is a student of the game now
he cuts one of the best promos in the
business and he got my attention with
his promo so he's a guy that's had a
career that many many would love to have
he's been in it over 20 years longer
than i have
and
it's going to it's going to be an
interesting challenge because
in my documentary a while back on any i
said
as as an active performer you never want
to come off the road because if you come
off the road to get soft an nfl football
player tell you the same thing you go
through off season you got to get
calloused up and get ready to go right
so he's ready to go and so i got my work
cut out for for me uh on a saturday
april 2nd two night event april 2nd 3rd
and i'm going to be there whipping some
ass
and so when you say you're doing it for
you what do you what do you mean by that
well when i left i didn't want to leave
you know wrestlemania 19 i you know my
neck had presented some problems right
and uh you know after i'd gotten spiked
and dropped on my head back in 99 i had
three four fused up and it was time for
me to ride off into sunset and do
something else so this this comeback
means a lot to me
uh as i've you know been getting back in
ring shape and i'm gonna go out there
and do the absolute best i can but i've
said this uh i said this on my biography
again or just refer back to that too
many times here but go for it you know
my wife uh knows how much i love her my
family uh knows how much i love them uh
my daughter's and my stepdaughter know
how much i love them but uh professional
wrestling they call it sports
entertainment these days is the number
one passion in my life you know i like
to hunt i like to fish i like to ride my
four-wheelers but but the business of
sports entertainment is in my blood so
to get a chance to go back on the on the
world's grandest stage and one of the
greatest stadiums of all time
means a lot to me so i'm doing this for
the fans i'm doing this for wwe but i'm
doing this for me number one stone cold
steve austin here on the rich eisen show
on steve austin day 316 broken skull
american lager available today um we
have a game here uh stone cold called
start bench cut where you got to choose
one you got a bench one you gotta cut
one i've got three
um items for you
and we're gonna we're gonna run through
them if you don't mind playing start
bench cut with us right here
automatically see if i got any good
answers okay here we go hit the drop
right here
please to start stop
sit down and be quiet
here we go start bench cut right here uh
on the rich eyes and [ __ ] can i use the
same answer more than once no these
they're different they're i think you'll
you'll you'll see we'll see okay uh you
got the uh the music at least there you
go stone cold steve austin start bench
cut you got to start one you got a bench
cone you got to cut one first one is
your favorite wwe segment okay i've got
three four right here there's the beer
bash okay where you drove a beer truck
to the ring and you hosed down the rock
vince and shane mcmahon
number two is the grocery store fighter
parker t
where you actually fought him in an
aisle of a grocery store the whole
grocery store
the whole supermarket uh and then the
third one is when you totally
uh assaulted vince mcmahon
in a hospital room
bed
and hit him atop the head with a bedpan
where you snuck in
in full hospital gown and mask
your
your identity so you have to start one
your favorite one bench one which is
kind of second place and cut one which
one stone called steve austin it is
really impossible
i mean that's the that's the one i guess
that's the whole idea of the game you
want to make it easy
okay i i gotta
what's my time limit
you can focus
all right
man every single one of those was a
blast
i'm going to cut
vince mcmahon and bedpan oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
you know going into i think that was to
go home promo for wrestlemania 15
against rock
uh you know drive that beer truck in
there and then the other one is raising
hell and where whatever town that was at
the green frog grocery store doing ten
thousand dollars with a book or tea
it's hard for me to start cut or bench
anybody right i quit
wait a second stone cold don't quit
on this one i mean those are those are
such iconic moments for me as like i'd
be disrespecting you know one of the
guys by picking one over the other the
beer truck is number one i mean come on
you drove a beer truck i drive trying to
be homeboy
all right next one we'll move on here's
the next one start bench i don't think
that any easier uh
start bench cut you have to pick a tag
team partner
wow jim ross paul heyman or vince
mcmahon guys yeah okay
but i'm going with my guy uh jim ross
paul heyman is so instrumental in my
career yes if it wasn't for any of these
men here yes i wouldn't be here so i
love them all and
vince mcmahon would never hear me say
that in a million years but i'm going to
go with jim ross on this because he was
there when i had my neck surgery he was
there to reunite myself with the company
when i had parted ways due to some bad
booking decisions in my opinion so i'm
going with jim ross okay
all right i'm gonna i'm gonna bench paul
and i'm gonna cut vents
and that's the bottom line because i
said so
[Music]
last one steve i don't know this this
may be the toughest one of them all
and i apologize in advance start bench
cut your drink of choice beer whiskey or
tequila
all right
i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna cut the
whiskey okay cut the whiskey i'm gonna
bench the tequila
because i bring it back in rotation
and
[Applause]
you do not you will never miss an
opportunity to promote there you go yeah
there it is right in front of you you
know we're releasing this i'm fixing to
leave here you flip me one out yeah
i'm leaving here to go right to the
brewery because we've got it i mean it's
it's geographically sound right yeah oh
geographically sounds good
so
uh yesterday i was down there signing
pre-signing some stuff
and uh had a couple and then uh like
today i'll have a couple because you
know it's the thing to do to party with
the people that we're doing a release
party with sure uh but then it'll be
back to hardcore training for
wrestlemania 38 because you know i got a
can of whoop ass it might be the last
can i have in me but i've got one last
can for kevin owens and i'm going to
give it to him i like it fine fashion
get up
cheers sir cheers
okay here we go
steve we were watching that promo coach
here
the one with coach where it was kind of
the height of the what era too where
you're just like more beer what more
beer what some tequila what whiskey what
just caught a guy's [ __ ]
awesome because i was always trying to
bust him you know he's trying not to
laugh i know all the time i dared to had
him a couple times but he's such a pro
he was awesome
this is really good yeah hey man
you know like the the ipa you know i was
just specific on that because you know i
like different i like something a little
bit more mid-palate i don't want to
linger too long i don't want to be too
bitter
that beer was built specifically for me
and it's awesome this awesome beer but
you know in a beer like this you just
want something you just drink a bunch of
and this is that damn beer i mean
because you can't drink a whole bunch of
those ipas i mean you can and i can but
i mean it's not advisable
i recommend it but she can drink ten of
these
that was an epic start bench cut by the
way good job good job tj tj came up with
all those runs and i can't uh take any
credit for that i kind of i kind of
cramped the bed on the first three but
yeah
i mean look those are three of your more
iconic moments we didn't even include
obviously you give delivering the line
that causes today to be steve austin
yeah but
those are pretty epic i mean who helped
come up with the the belt steve the
stone cold belt hey man that's a great
question because i was you know hanging
around four shows we're always kind of
kicking it killing time people wonder
how you kill time is telling stories a
lot of guys played cards a lot of times
i'd be hanging out with bubba ray or
chris jericho talking rock and roll but
at this point in time i was hanging out
the road warriors and animal and hulk
and they were sitting there and said god
dang i was really starting to catch on
fire and the big thing back in the day
you know if someone really blew the roof
off the joint you say oh man that was a
road warrior pop so road wars are really
over right and uh they said steve he
said you ought to have your own belt you
ought to have the stone coal belt and i
guess i ran that by vents but it was a
road warrior's idea to come up with that
belt and we did
whose idea was it to hit him with a bed
pen was that just you saw that was
vince's idea
oh yeah man that segment is so much gold
in that me and mick foley are in this
tiny closet while vince is doing his
stuff and he breaks out mr sacco and
says that's about to be his new finish
maneuver and we're in there like two big
ass guys in a little bitty room just
laughing our asses off and they said hey
man you guys got to keep it down while
vince is doing this stuff and so when i
found out i was gonna hit him with this
you know that thing is stainless steel
and so i'm bouncing it off my head
trying to get the right acoustics and
try to find that sweet spot
because
you know when your boss says you've got
to lay me out he's already laid out but
when you gotta you hit somebody with a
bedpan and you're in the middle of a hot
angle you don't want to just go dink
you got to rear back and bring it so i
just found a sweet spot on my head and
then on the fly you know i'm an expert
at hitting
hitting people with certain objects
yeah and so it worked out great and
people still talk about that moment
like us yeah back here in this day all
right cheers to you uh everybody uh what
you said um
and uh brokenskullbeard.com is really
good man and then um
by the way
our kudos to our refrigerator this thing
is really cold right i mean this is ice
cold it's stone cold and also rich the
moment steve was talking about when it
all happened i told ruler that's the
t-shirt i have on the day the moment
that he's uh those lines to michael
hayes doc hendrix who he was at the time
and
wearing that today in honor of the man
and drinking some beer
but you know as mick foley said he goes
you know i could have got that promo
just like i did it would have been great
but the fact that i was stitched up
there's a little bit of blood in my
mouth just kind of added to the it was
an exclamation point on the promo it's
certainly great notice by mick foley
at steve austin bsr on twitter and
instagram broken skullbeer.com this is
really good stuff it goes down a little
too easy i've got a workout
very honestly that was a plan and we
will see you at wrestlemania sir yeah
raising hell is only i can thanks for
staying and thanks for coming here on
your on your day really appreciate it
thank you for having me uh richard
awesome and love all you guys and that's
the bottom line
because stone cold said so
oh yes
oh yeah
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here